[Risate]
stiamo al dada porti la ludoteca parco
giochi gigante contiamo di fare grandi
cose e oggi giocheremo nascondino qua il
parco giochi sarà super divertente ma
poi si fa certo perché se questo video
raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace faremo le
altre sale
quarti grazie mille per averti ospitati
nuovamente grazie riuscite a riconoscere
che video e questo scrivetelo nei
commenti e ora iniziamo subito con il
nascondino perché sarà una pedina
estreme spiega oggi secondo voi seguite
in caratteri integravano da vivere uno
mani siamo subito prima ora andiamo per
decidere chi inizia il nascondino
entreremo qua in questo campetto di
calcio chi riesce a fare gol inizierà
per primo io sono una grandissima
schiappa calcio e non capisco neanche le
regole non capisco niente e quindi
io faccio da portiere adesso
trova proprio a tirare anche se so già
che non ci riusciva mettiamo
piano di dire il falso ballet dal petto
6 colpito il portiere
vari proviamo allora
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ha prodotto
a vito vitale quindi inizierò abitare a
nasconderti bene mentre pitari si
nasconde io mi metto dentro la casetta a
contare si nasconderà
piccolo lotito non posso spiare a
[Musica]
tempo scaduto andiamo subito a cercare
il palo state bene attenti anche voi ce
lo vedete prima di me scrivetelo nei
commenti
forse vicino allo scivolo mettiamo non
c'è nessuno qua
[Musica]
beh allora provate entrare dentro al
parco giochi e vediamo se riusciamo a
trovarlo andiamo
non so se salire d'acqua oppure salire
da la forza per risalire quale
ma
vitale l'ho trovato ora non mi resta che
andare a prenderlo ma cosa che è venuta
in mente a nasconderti lì nella parte
trasparente lo vedo benissimo lì tanto
ora arriva a prenderti vediamo se
riuscirà a scappare
ok si sale da qua andiamo ok sto salendo
su per raggiungere vitale lui non è
ancora scappato non capisco perché è
inutile che continui a nasconderti ti ho
vinto 6 la stura il tubo vedo anche
l'ombra nel tubo guardate eccolo lì lo
vedete
sta spostando discopatia
di fondare di là a prenderlo wow che c'è
un ponticello
tanto ora ti prendono rosina ko mi
prenderà invece vedremo
lei tu puoi riuscire a vincere se riesci
a tornare nella casetta prima che io ti
prenda
va bene ci sono tante ore di pregio
così così vicina venuto non puoi
scappare ormai so dove stai facendo
laggiù
o no ha trovato un passaggio che fosse
anche da quella parte devo raggiungere
dato più basso da qua o da lì prova a
passare da questo ponte non pensare di
sfuggirmi ormai detto raggiungendo
o noi c'era giu presto sbrighiamoci
eccolo questo era il nascondiglio di
vitale ferma lo scopo sono avanti ciao
perché ha trovato
ciao
più scampo
a scappare di
vaio
che questo gesto si offre ritrovato
trovato il suo nascondiglio perché il 38
degli e non era proprio la famiglia ho
visto che ti vedevo che là fuori
vai a contare non sbirciare
vai dentro la casetta
vitale loggetta ho un'idea per questo
nascondiglio invece di nascondermi in
questa sala di dada parti andrò
nell'altra sala
più difficile capitale mi trovi
mi chiamo c
ecco qua l'altra sala da fare mi potrei
nascondere ma sia un altro campetto di
calcio ma se un altro parco giochi
guardate quanti dubbi li mi sa che mi
pongo qua
vediamo da dove si entra
si entrava qua
ecco secondo me vitale non mi troverà
qua ma sappiamo fin sopra nel tubo
colorato
dal è già arrivato
l'acqua nella seconda sala
devo nascondermi in quella parte del
tubo giro al centro
squadra certo il proprio li
sento tanto
centrando quando chiudi ti
è rimasto cifrato
vitale troppo grande e non riuscivo a
fare ma li meglio che mi spiego devo
andare si entra altro po
guardate che bene come ora tissimo
arrivandovi dare chiari
viene fatta
io tu
[Musica]
beh penso di essere nascosta veniva
guardate
0re strade ma dove
ti ho trovato
sappiamo da evitare
tanto riso non riesce a passare lì
addio già da
capo che succede
è caduta di nuovo si
aspetta
ciao ciao anche se hai trovato il mio
lato degli a note riuscito a prendermi
ora senza da quel festival viii
secolo su vitale
[Applauso]
è troppo lento
o no devo postate da qua
aiuto come si passa da qua beh almeno
vitale rimarrà incastrato tra infatti
prendere
ecco cosa di uscita ma vediamo prima se
di valerio superare questa parte o no
entro maggio su incastrato prima
[Musica]
che ho preso solo un vicino a prenderti
fitto secondo era un lavoro vitale ha
trovato b1 school jack è riuscito a
prendermi eravamo proprio per scorsi qua
e là scotta cuore passiamo ora al terzo
round terzo round tocca a me
vediamo
veloce però c'è veloce ci nascondiamo
qui
ciao zucca e o no se il mister potevo ho
una zucca non lo so
sono quei nel castello
magari lei non se ne accorge
il concerto davvero un bel nascondiglio
non riesce a trovarmi
proprio in fondo non mi troverà mai qui
sì sì forse proprio nella tra sala
controllare ulteriore sto qui
oporto
e così via tra
via via
scappiamo scappiamo
io ho preso qualche altro a casa ei tiri
puzzolenti
ma io sono caduto dalle scale
aiuto ultim'ora ultim'ora questo è il
round decisivo
devo nascondermi io vado a portare e
rimanete convinta andiamo a contare 12
dove stai dando
ok andiamo nella casetta allora allora
andiamo
a
16128 132 134 e 137
128 penso proprio che si sia nascosta
allora andiamo subito a controllare dove
si sarà nascosta vediamo
qui non credo che si sarà nascosta
perché mi sono nascosto prima io qua
qui no probabilmente no perché è troppo
piccolo secondo me nascosta qui
io penso che sia questo il posto dove
sia nascosta nyt ha quindi iniziato bene
andiamo a trovarla
brava ma che ti si è nascosta qui nella
zona scivolo
viviamo
oppure oppure
no
forse sopra anita dove sei
ma si è nascosta proprio bene
proviamo a fare lo zoom per cercare di
trovarla qui da qualche parte dove sara
ciao e mi stai lì da dove si è nascosta
è un osso duro non vuole parlare qui
proviamo a cercarla qui
che c'è da guardare tu hai visto dove si
è nascosta anita per caso
ma si è mosso ti sei mosso
sei un po sospetto tue
cos'è l'amore
no non c'è chi
nemmeno lei ma non riesco a capire dov'è
che sia nascosta
eppure ho sentito comore qui priva
ma questa era un rumore che proveniva
proprio da lì ma qui ci sono solo delle
palline
e quelle parti si sono mosse secondo me
c'è qualcosa di sospetto là sotto
andiamo a vedere chi se lo ricorda la
strada per uscire da qui adesso o no
sono riuscito ad uscire noi ci credo
allora andiamo a controllare perché
c'erano quei movimenti la
mi sembra tutto normale
sono però quasi sicuro di aver visto
qualcosa muoversi qui
ho capito forse anita si è nascosta
proprio qui e adesso le faccio bello
scherzetto
no non era
se trovo spostare tutte le palline
magari riuscire a fuori prima o poi
no è anche il pitcher
no
no non c'è neanche qui
si sa però dove sarà
mi riposo un po qui
[Musica]
sorpresa
ebbene sì lieto che
non ci credo non vi è ritrovata
ti ho preso mi hai fregato trovate
pensate di riuscire a scappare e
aspettavo momento quanti round hai vinto
[Musica]
questa partita può essere evitato
scrivete nei commenti chi ha vinto ma
soprattutto volete una rivincita
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete un
altro video qua da parti grazie ancora
dalla parte per averci grazie anche
questa volta è un posto bellissimo per
le feste di compleanno eventi o solo per
vedere detto rivellini infine grazie
ancora da fare e ora vi lasciamo quattro
case lines più cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cade su quella che
preferite buona visione